le dumont d'urville vient d'accoster à
la base navale de brest après des essais
effectués en mer avec munitie relie
traque les imperfections constatées lors
des tests dans le compartiment machine
ce jour là ils découvrent une fuite
j'ai démontré c'est la fuite laissant la
centrale
comme aide alimentaire
tous les systèmes qui fonctionnent avec
lui
le second maître ronnie est un des rares
officiers mariniers sûtra marin affecté
sur le dumont d'urville de la vie
rapportera en juin à fort de france son
port-base 2008 en tant que volontaire
j'étais déjà en martinique sur leurs
effets seront tous là de sourire en
sortant je suis content de retourner sur
le pont supérieur le second maître
romaric est un tout petit peu inquiet
cela fait deux minutes qui cherche un
objet utile tableau
ça veut dire que là vous découvrez le
bateau si oui ça a pris mais après on
s'y faire après petit à petit faut juste
qu'on s'habitue aux bateaux cola briois
et puis après tout roule quoi ce marin
né à lifou en nouvelle calédonie est âgé
de 33 ans il s'occupe de tout ce qui
concerne l'appareillage et l'accostage
du bateau le second maître romaric est
heureux de faire partie de l'équipage du
dumont d'urville
c'est une chose si pour moi de retourner
au brésil ainsi pas chez moi mais moi
j'aurai du soleil le bâtiment de soutien
et d'assistance autres maires dumont
d'urville est armé par deux équipages
composés chacun de 21 marins
le personnel s'approprie actuellement
deux navires avant son départ pour les
antilles où il va effectuer des missions
militaires et interministériels ça peut
être aussi des missions de protection de
nos intérêts ou de lutte contre le
narcotrafic donc le narcotrafic est une
quête une menace présent dans toute la
zone caraïbe antilles en particulier à
bord du bateau plusieurs équipements
dans cette embarcation de servitude et
peut être très utile notamment en cas de
catastrophe naturelle cette embarcation
est capable d'aller jusqu'à la plage de
s'ouvrir sur l'avant et de débarquer un
petit 4 iv du matériel des vivres et
même des équipes de renfort de par
exemple d
et du personnel médical le dumont
d'urville quittera la métropole en mai
pour la martinique
c'est l'un des quatre bâtiment de
soutien d'assistance qui équipent
l'outre-mer les trois autres sont
déployés en nouvelle calédonie polynésie
et à la réunion